avec vous Hélène frad bien sûr bonjour
Hélène bonjour Pauline à la une de la
presse on en parlait à l'instant les
élections législatives en Israël c'est
aujourd'hui les bureaux de vote viennent
d'ouvrir ce sont les cinquième élections
en moins de 4 ans l'actuel Premier
ministre centriste hier lapide
pourra-t-il formé une nouvelle coalition
ou l'ex Premier ministre l'inoxydable
Benyamine Netanyahu qui est poursuivi
pour corruption pourra-t-il revenir au
pouvoir les deux dirigeants en tout cas
font la une ce matin du Jérusalem post
qui évoque la volonté des électeurs de
mettre fin à l'instabilité politique qui
s'évite en Israël depuis trois ans le
quotidien conservateur dit comprendre la
lassitude électorale des Israéliens et
il tente de les mobiliser en expliquant
que la course est si serrée et ses
résultats si cruciaux pour l'avenir
d'Israël qu'il est encore plus important
de voter cette fois-ci chaque vote votez
demande le journal et c'est d'ailleurs
ce énormément aussi le quotidien arrête
ce qui dit voter oui mais surtout pas
certainement pas pour Benyamine
Netanyahou ni pour le sioniste religieux
est Amar benbir convoite ici tenant une
autobiographie du patron du liquide ce
disciple du rabbin raciste et anti-arabe
mère Cannes patrons du parti d'extrême
droite Hotmail audite force juive et
devenue une figure incontournable de la
vie politique israélienne depuis moins
d'un an et la bête noire du quotidien de
gauche qui demande aux électeurs de
stopper net un éventuel retour au
pouvoir de Netanyahou dans le cadre
d'une alliance je cite avec l'extrémiste
ultra nationaliste Itamar benville
elle a une également on en parlait aussi
dans le journal la décision les
autorités iraniennes d'organiser dans
les jours qui viennent à Téhéran des
procès public pour près d'un millier de
personnes arrêtaient lors des
manifestations ces dernières semaines
d'après le gardiennes jusqu'à 2000
personnes pourraient être poursuivi pour
avoir protesté contre la mort de Marsa
aminis cette jeune femme décédée en
garde à vue après avoir été battus par
la police des mœurs pour avoir mal porté
son hijab son voile islamique le
quotidien précise que ces manifestants
seront jugés pour action
subversive je cite voir pour certains
d'entre eux collaboration avec des
gouvernements étrangers à l'étranger
précisément la condamnation de cette
répression en Iran s'élargit selon le
site iron wire les déclarations le
week-end dernier de cet homme Hussein
salami il est le commandant des Gardiens
de la Révolution il a averti les
protestataires que le pouvoir ne
tolérerait plus de manifestations
préparation donc aurait amené l'Union
européenne à envisager de classer les
Gardiens de la Révolution islamique qui
sont à la pointe de cette répression
comme organisation terroriste ce que les
États-Unis ont d'ailleurs fait déjà on
fait des 2019 les États-Unis et la nous
la Cour suprême rouvre un dossier très
sensible celui de la discrimination
positive dans les universités du pays
discrimination positive qui les oblige à
prendre en compte la couleur de peau ou
l'origine éthique ethnique pardon des
candidats dans l'examen de leur dossier
mais après la remise en cause du droit
constitutionnel à l'avortement la plus
haute instance juridique américaine
va-t-elle faire de même avec la
discrimination positive ce serait en
effet une possibilité d'après de New
York Times ce qui précise que la Cour
suprême se penche actuellement sur les
procédures d'admission dans deux des
plus anciennes facs américaines
l'université d'Harvard est celle de
Caroline du Nord le journal rappelle à
cette occasion que la discrimination
positive dans les université est très
critiquée depuis le départ par les
milieux conservateurs qui vont jusqu'à y
voir une forme de racisme inversé alors
que les progressistes n'en font partie
ces jeunes militantes considèrent au
contraire la discrimination positive
comme un moyen de soutenir les minorités
de favoriser la diversité pour sa part
le New York Times considère qu'une
décision défavorable à la discrimination
positive dans les universités seraient
je cite une preuve supplémentaire du
virage à droite de la Cour suprême après
la nomination de trois juges par
l'ancien président de notre Trump le
Wall Street Journal qui précise quant à
lui que les juges envisagent de remettre
en question les pratiques d'admission de
Harvard et l'université de Caroline du
Nord au motif qu'elle pourra constituer
une forme de discrimination illégale
envers les étudiants d'origine asiatique
estime lui que la faiblesse principale
des arguments des défenseurs de cette
discrimination positive et sont
incapables de dire quand les préjugés
ratio dans les admissions prendre enfin
aux États-Unis établissant ainsi une
discrimination positive ou eux a duré
éternellement une perspective
inadmissible pour le journal
on ne se quitte pas là-dessus Hélène la
rubrique justice toujours quoique dans
un tout autre registre c'est un faux qui
devrait beaucoup intéressé notre ami
Florent rodo le Monde rapporte en effet
que l'Argentine a établi il y a peu et
pour la première fois un droit de visite
pour les maîtres et maîtresses de chiens
dans le cadre des divorces les juges ont
motivé cette décision par le fait que
les animaux sont des êtres sensibles qui
éprouvent le manque et qui sont affectés
par la séparation de leur maître une
question très sensible Pauline dans un
pays qui compte près de 80% de
propriétaires d'animaux domestiques mais
les Argentins ne sont pas les seuls
semble-t-il tenir à leur toutou et alors
mets tout comme à la prunelle de leurs
yeux le Huffington posse fait état d'un
sondage qui indique que 40 pour 45% des
Français propriétaires d'animaux
aimeraient être enterrés avec leur
animal de mystique et les propriétaires
de chiens d'ailleurs sont plus nombreux
à 51% que le propriétaire de chat 47% et
laisse pour eux cette pratique est
interdite pour le moment en France
contrairement à l'Allemagne au
Royaume-Uni ou à la Suisse c'est ce
qu'on appelle un marronnier de la
Toussaint un espace merci beaucoup
Hélène une